man how hard was it for you to find
investors for pink zone
well I have to say I could it in no
budget which is because we had to spend
like I'd say between 5,000 and 6,000
which is no budget in terms of of movie
making and they were all private savings
so so we we went and make the movie with
literally no phones and no one involved
so so so in a way it was it was making
us feel free and but I mean I think that
even though that was the story of this
movie I would tell young filmmakers not
to be afraid of getting money you have
to go and get the money where it is out
there so so so getting investors is not
a bad thing it is not going to ruin your
creative vision on the contrary I think
that the best on the contrary it can be
seen as a limit but if you are as
serious and as good as a filmmaker you
will always find a way to go around that
and you tell your story the story you
have in your heart in your mind so I
don't think that would be a limit even
even when a lot of people are putting
money from everywhere and then ask for
people to for certain kind of things but
it's like every other limit on a movie
set up I mean when you're making V there
are a lot of limits and there are a lot
of obstacles and you just have to go
around it around the mountain and just
find a way to just continue and keep
telling the story so no crowdfunding you
didn't want to try your hand at that was
about it the thing was because we were
just wanted to shoot that fast that we
had the money there sleeping for us so
we just went out and made the movie and
we didn't want to to wait too long for
crowd finally and - and
to put our hopes on hold you know it's
like when you when you were doing
crowdfunding you it's great but you you
can also be waiting longer and longer
than expected and then the level of
interest for the story and commitment is
getting down and down and down
so whereas for pings oh it was kind of a
yeah for me the reference in the way we
did this film is virtue common we just
went indeed Roger common we kind of film
with just no budget and just shut it for
the sake of the story with just the help
of friends and our private savings for
your next film which I know you're
you're playing this crime drama thank
you do you plan to do a bigger budget
yeah okay yeah for me this one was
primarily to bring them to can make
teeth in and the next one the way I'm
writing it right now is on a much bigger
scale and even though it's very grand
into reality it will involve much more
money so so I'm open to any kind of
investments can be can go from
crowdfunding to private investors it's
we would go where who will be interested
to to finance it do you plan on on
mapping that out like do you know
certain people that you can ask or do
you plan let's launch the crowdfunding
campaign and then maybe sometimes
investors will match certain things I
mean do you have an idea yeah I know
that with especially with the film
festivals we're imprisoning things on
right now a lot of people are asking me
okay what's next
and I'm talking about them about the
story and I so I made these people who
are because they saw things and loved it
so much they are committed to maybe help
finds the next one and so that's why
this movie also is great as a way to
engage people to finance the next one
and that's why also for the next film
festivals we're gonna do with bings own
especially the big ones in Europe we're
gonna still continue
present pings on as a way to finance the
next one
you